Our work is the first to look at how
humans impact ecosystems in a really
fine grained way. I'm Stefani Crabtree;
I'm an archaeologist and archaeoecologist.
So The Archaeoecology Project
is a project that brings together
archaeologists, ecologists, and
anthropologists, and computer modelers to
try to understand the ways in which
humans impact ecosystems and the ways
ecosystems impact humans. My name's
Jennifer Dunne; I'm an ecologist and a
complex systems scientist, and I study
ecological networks. An ecological
network is a representation of an
ecosystem, and one type of ecological
network is a food web. Most food webs
that have been compiled and studied have
been put together without including
humans. One of the things that we've
started to do is to use an ecological
network framework to pull humans
explicitly into ecological analyses. And
what's useful about networks is that
sometimes it's difficult to understand
what kind of effects it would have to
remove this plant – let's say it went
extinct – would that have ripple effects
throughout the whole network as the
other animals scramble to eat something
else? Would that create pressures that we couldn't predict unless we had this
networked approach? The other interesting thing is people don't just eat. Like a
lot of animals do, we build shelters. We
make clothing. We use things that we take
from the environment in important
rituals. And so in in The Archaeoecology
Project we're not just looking at food
consumption. We're looking at these
myriad ways in which we impact
environments. What we're driving at is
really trying to use food webs and
ecological networks to approach issues
of sustainability, of socio ecological
networks, in a new kind of way. Within our
team we've published two of the first
highly resolved food webs that include
humans. Jennifer Dunne led a team that published
a marine food web that included humans,
and then I led a team that published the
first highly resolved terrestrial food
web – that's for the
ancestral pueblo case study. We approached these in slightly different ways but in
the end what we are getting is this
ability to cross-compare the ways that
people impact ecosystems in different
ways worldwide. We're looking at multiple
sites where there is incredibly good
preservation, where we can really
disentangle the human effect from the
environmental effect, and where we can
look at a really deep diachronic
perspective. These six cases where we're
working are the ancestral Pueblo
Southwest; we're working in the Norse
Atlanti;c we're working in the Pacific
Northwest, where the indigenous peoples
there developed a deep time
coevolution with their ecosystem; we're
working in French Polynesia, which is
kind of similar to that Pacific
Northwest –a very different environment
but that very deep coevolution of
terrestrial and marine environments. In
Europe people were foragers and then
they move toward farming so we're
looking at some of those earliest
indications of that and then we're also
working in the western desert of
Australia. We can look at these six cases
these six incredibly detailed cases and
look at the ways that people come into
their environments, that they experiment
with the environment and with the
ecosystem, that they develop practices
that are sustainable or sometimes non-sustainable, and we can take that and we
can learn from it. These systems that we're studying are
very different in some ways, and as we
start to understand the patterns and how
humans interact with other species and
use other species, we can understand
those patterns – whether they're similar
different across systems – are there
generalities or are there specificities?
And we can understand that in relation
to the constraints that climate presents,
or the opportunities that different
kinds of ecological habitats present, or
how cultural norms for example, or social
hierarchy affect how humans interact
with other species.
There's also aspects of the work that
we're doing that will allow us to look
at simple versus complex interactions and
that gives us a way to quantify
technology use innovation and a variety
of questions around that so it provides
a new lens not only on sustainability
but also on interesting issues in
innovation and technology. Once we
understand people's roles better we can
start to ask more questions about the
sustainability of systems that include
humans in terms of how they compare to
other predators and how they interact
with all the species they feed on and
all the species that those feed on as
well.